OK, so you call a hotline, and then a complete stranger tries to figure out how to help you, on the spot. That idea seems to have begun in the 1950s. The first suicide hotline in the United States was created in the early '60s by a guy in San Francisco, who was a priest and also a journalist. And it was just him answering the phone at first.
好的，当你拨打热线电话时，一个完全陌生的人会立刻想办法帮你。这个想法似乎起源于20世纪50年代。美国第一条自杀干预热线是20世纪60年代初由旧金山的一位牧师兼记者建立的。起初，只有他一个人在接电话。
Ads on matchbooks and sides of buses said, "Thinking of ending it all? Call Bruce," which, by the way, was not his real name. His real name was Bernard Mayes. But of course, the power of anonymity is so important to any hotline. People would call. And sometimes he could help them precisely because he had no connection to their life at all. Like, they could say anything to him. In those pre-internet days, that was completely new, to harness that kind of anonymity, the intimacy of it, this way, over the phone.
火柴盒和公交车侧面的广告上写着：“想结束这一切吗？打给布鲁斯。”顺便说一下，那不是他的真名。他的真名是伯纳德·梅斯。但当然，匿名权对于任何热线来说都非常重要。人们会打电话。有时他能帮助他们，正是因为他与他们的生活毫无关联。他们可以对他畅所欲言。在互联网出现之前的那些日子里，通过电话利用这种匿名性和亲密感是全新的尝试。
These days, of course, there are all kinds of hotlines for people in all sorts of situations-- prayer hotlines, psychic hotlines, also hotlines for homework help, for new moms. There's a hotline for owners of three-legged dogs, and another one specifically for anybody who swallows one of those-- you know those little, round button batteries? That one also handles any kid who pushes it up their nose.
如今，当然，各类人群在各种情况下都有各式各样的热线——祈祷热线、通灵热线，还有家庭作业求助热线、新手妈妈热线。有一个专门为三条腿狗的主人准备的热线，还有一个专门为误吞了那些——你知道那些小圆纽扣电池的人准备的热线。那条热线也处理把电池塞进鼻孔的孩子的情况。
Today we're going to devote our entire show to one phone call that happened on one hotline, a very unusual hotline. And then we have everything that followed from that one call. It takes you inside this world that I think either you're already in this world, or it's totally invisible to you. Like it's all around you. You don't even register that this world is there.
今天，我们要把整期节目献给某条热线上的一个电话，那是一条非常不寻常的热线。接着，我们还会讲讲那个电话之后发生的一切。它将带你进入这个世界，我想你要么已经在其中，要么对它视而不见。它就像环绕在你身边。你甚至都没有意识到这个世界的存在。
Mary Harris tells what happened. She's the host of Slate's daily news podcast, What Next. One quick note, some parts of this phone call might not be great for young children to hear. I suppose I could have given you this warning before mentioning that part about pushing batteries up your nose. But anyway, here's Mary with Act 1, "The Call."
玛丽·哈里斯讲述了发生的事情。她是Slate每日新闻播客《What Next》的主持人。简单提醒一下，这个通话中的某些部分可能不太适合年幼的孩子听。我想我本可以在提到把电池塞进鼻子里那部分之前就给你警告。但无论如何，这是玛丽带来的第一幕，“那通电话”。
The call on this story took place a few years ago.
这个故事里的通话发生在几年前。
Thank you for calling.
感谢您的致电。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放中]
It's a call to a hotline of sorts, though one I'd never heard about before and was surprised to learn existed. This is the music you hear when you're waiting for an operator.
这是一个某种意义上的热线电话，尽管这是我以前从未听说过且惊讶于其存在的。这是你在等待接线员时听到的音乐。
(RAPPING) I tried to break free. You tried to keep me bound. I tried to live right. You tried to keep me down. But now I'm going--
(说唱) 我试图挣脱。你试图束缚我。我试图正道而行。你试图压制我。但现在我要——
Never Use Alone. It's Jessie.
“绝不独自使用”（Never Use Alone），我是杰西。
Hi. My name is Kimber.
你好。我叫金伯。
How are you?
你好吗？
Good, how are you?
很好，你呢？
I'm good. Let me catch your name one more time.
我很好。能请你再说一次你的名字吗？
Kimber.
金伯。
That's what I thought, OK.
我就猜是这个，好的。
The woman taking this call, her name's Jessie. She's a nurse, and she's taken thousands of these.
接这个电话的女人叫杰西。她是一名护士，已经接听了数千个这样的电话。
All right, let me get my book, Kimber. I've never talked to you before. I'm glad you called. Have you called us before?
好了，让我拿上我的本子，金伯。我以前没跟你谈过话。我很高兴你打了电话。你以前打过我们这里吗？
No, this is my first time.
没有，这是我第一次。
Oh.
哦。
I just got out of rehab yesterday, and I don't want to use by myself.
我昨天刚从康复中心出来，我不想独自用药。
OK, all right. So what are you going to use, Kimber, and how are you going to use it?
好的，没问题。那么你打算用什么，金伯，你打算怎么用？
I'm injecting heroin.
我正在注射海洛因。
OK.
好的。
Probably fentanyl.
可能是芬太尼。
Probably fentanyl, OK.
可能是芬太尼，好的。
The hotline is called "Never Use Alone." And the idea is, if you're going to inject heroin or do a speedball, something like that, and there's no one around, you can dial them up. Someone will stay on the line, make sure you're OK. If it seems like you've overdosed, they'll call the paramedics.
这条热线叫“绝不独自使用”。其理念是，如果你打算注射海洛因或使用“极速球”（speedball）之类的药物，且身边没人，你可以拨打这个电话。会有人在线陪着你，确保你没事。如果看起来你服药过量了，他们会叫救护车。
All right, let me get some information, OK, baby? All right, give me your callback number in case we get disconnected.
好的，让我记下一些信息，好吗，亲爱的？好的，告诉我你的回拨号码，以防我们掉线。
Jessie gets the caller's phone number and address, just in case she has to call the ambulance. The caller, Kimber, is in Massachusetts. Jessie is down in Georgia.
杰西记下了来电者的电话号码和地址，以防她不得不叫救护车。来电者金伯在马萨诸塞州。杰西在乔治亚州。
You got your door unlocked?
你门锁好了吗？
Let me check. Hold on. Yeah, it's unlocked now.
让我检查一下。等一下。是的，现在没锁了。
OK, so make sure I'm on speakerphone.
好的，确保我的通话开着免提。
Yep.
好的。
All right, you're by yourself in your home, in your apartment?
好的，你一个人在家里，在你的公寓里吗？
Yeah.
是的。
OK, do you have Narcan?
好的，你有纳洛酮（Narcan）吗？
I do.
有的。
Set it out for me. And if you've got anything else extra that you don't need to do your job-- if you just picked up, if you got some extra rigs, put away anything you don't need, OK?
拿出来放在我能看见的地方。如果你还有其他不需要的操作工具——如果你刚买的，或者有额外的注射器，把不需要的东西都收起来，好吗？
OK.
好的。
Because God forbid I have to call the ambulance-- they'll take your shit when they leave, and I don't want them to do that.
因为天哪，如果我不得不叫救护车，他们离开时会收走你的那些东西，我不希望那样。
OK. Hold on. Let me put everything away then in the bathroom. There's like a bunch of stuff out.
好的。等一下。那我先把浴室里所有东西都收起来。那里有一堆东西。
Yeah, just close the door, you know, or whatever. Just don't leave it right where you're at. How long have you been abstinent?
是的，把门关上就行，或者随便怎样。只是别把它就留在你所在的地方。你戒断多久了？
About a month.
大约一个月。
OK. So you know your tolerance is in the dirt, right, baby?
好的。那你清楚你的耐受性已经降到最低了，对吧，亲爱的？
Yeah.
是的。
OK. All right, so listen, so I'll stay on the phone with you. If you want to just-- I mean, if you want to do points at a time or half a point at a time, we'll take it as slow as you want. If you would feel better video chatting me, we can do a Jitsi or something, OK?
好的。好了，听着，我会一直在线陪着你。如果你想——我是说，如果你想一次分点剂量注射，或者一次注射一半，我们可以按你想的速度慢慢来。如果你觉得视频聊天更好，我们可以用Jitsi之类的，好吗？
OK.
好的。
So you can hear like in the beginning, I'm upbeat. I'm happy to talk to her.
所以你可以听到，在开始时，我很乐观。我很高兴与她交谈。
I spoke with Jessie, the nurse.
我和护士杰西谈过。
But you hear my voice change. Like, I--
但你听到了我的声音在变化。就像，我——
Yeah, what is that?
是的，那是怎么回事？
She was speaking with some speed, with some urgency. I just-- I knew she wasn't going to be careful. My mama spirit kicked in immediately. It's a sixth sense that you develop when you do these calls.
她说话很快，带有一种紧迫感。我只是——我知道她不会小心谨慎的。我的母性本能立刻被激发了。这是你在进行这些通话时培养出来的一种第六感。
She's not connecting with you. She's like, just, I'm here to get this done.
她没有和你建立联系。她就像是，只是，我在这里是为了完成这件事。
She was there to do a job.
她是为了工作而来。
So all I ask you to do is you let me know as soon as you push your first dose. You let me know that you're done.
所以我请求你做的唯一一件事就是，当你推注第一剂时立刻告诉我。让我知道你完成了。
OK. Well, I have to hold my breath for a second because I have to do it in my neck. So I'm not going to be speaking for a second, but I'll let you know.
好的。嗯，我得屏住呼吸一会儿，因为我必须从脖子那里注射。所以我一会儿不能说话，但我会让你知道的。
OK.
好的。
So her neck?
所以是她的脖子？
Mm-hmm. She's doing it-- you can inject in your external jugular vein. But to do that, you have to hold your breath.
嗯。她在做这个——你可以注射到颈外静脉。但要做到这一点，你必须屏住呼吸。
Is that-- like, you do that when your other veins are blown out?
那是——就像，你在其他静脉都坏死时才会那样做吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
You're using terminology I don't understand, like half a point, a point. What does that mean?
你用的术语我不懂，比如“半点”（half a point）、“一点”（a point）。那是什么意思？
When they hopefully weigh their dope-- hopefully when you weigh your dope out, they're using a scale. And they measure it out in grams. 0.1 is a tenth of a gram, 0.2. I mean, that's drug user lingo for, we'll nickel and dime it right on in there.
当他们希望称量毒品时——希望他们在称量毒品时用了秤。他们以克为单位来计量。0.1是一克的十分之一，0.2。我的意思是，那是吸毒者的行话，我们会在那里精打细算。
Small doses are one way to try to stay safe when you're using a drug like heroin or fentanyl. But the truth is, you really have no idea what you're getting if you're buying drugs off the street.
小剂量是你在使用海洛因或芬太尼等药物时尝试保持安全的一种方式。但事实是，如果你从街上买药，你真的不知道自己买到了什么。
I said, I just need a second because I got to find a vein.
我说，我只需要一秒钟，因为我得找到静脉。
That's fine. We're in no rush.
没关系。我们不赶时间。
I just have really bad eyes, so it's like really hard to do.
我只是视力很差，所以这真的很难操作。
Oh, god. Oh, yeah.
天哪。哦，是的。
But like all the veins on my arms are like shot.
但我手臂上的所有静脉基本上都坏死了。
Yeah.
是的。
OK, I'm pushing it in.
好的，我正在推注。
All right, slow and easy, baby.
好的，慢点，轻松点，亲爱的。
All right, I'm pushing, and I'm letting the tourniquet go.
好的，我在推，我正在松开止血带。
OK, baby.
好的，亲爱的。
OK, I think I'm OK. I'm good.
好的，我想我没事。我很好。
All right, well, we're gonna stay on the phone for about five minutes, OK?
好的，那么，我们会在电话上待大约五分钟，好吗？
OK.
好的。
And then if you want to do more, then you can do a little bit more, OK?
然后如果你想再来一点，那么你可以再来一点，好吗？
Sometimes a person will call in wanting to talk. With the regulars, Jessie knows the names of their pets, keeps track of their birthdays. But her main job is just to stay on the line and check in every now and then. For this call, she was sitting at her kitchen table. Her husband walks in at some point for help with a Ziploc bag. But every minute or so, she's trying to get a read on Kimber.
有时人打电话进来只是想聊天。对于常客，杰西知道他们宠物的名字，记得他们的生日。但她的主要工作只是保持通话并时不时地查看一下。这次通话时，她正坐在餐桌旁。她的丈夫在某个时刻走进来寻求帮忙拿保鲜袋。但大约每过一分钟，她都在试图了解金伯的情况。
You good?
你还好吗？
Yeah.
是的。
OK.
好的。
About 60 seconds later, Jessie checks in again?
大约60秒后，杰西再次确认？
You OK, honey? Kimber? Kimber? Kimber? Kimber, I'm going to call your name about one more time, then I'm calling an ambulance. Kimber. Kimber? You better answer me. Kimber.
你还好吗，亲爱的？金伯？金伯？金伯？金伯，我再叫你最后一次，然后我就要叫救护车了。金伯。金伯？你最好回答我。金伯。
What are you thinking in this moment?
那一刻你在想什么？
I'm hoping that she just walked away from the phone. I try to give them 30 seconds, 30 of the longest seconds of your life. I try to give them 30 seconds to, oh, shit, I'm sorry. I walked away from the phone. Or my earbuds disconnected, or I hit the mute by accident. That's what I try to do-- 30 seconds.
我希望她只是离开了电话。我尽量给他们30秒，这30秒是你一生中最漫长的。我尽量给他们30秒去说，哦，该死，抱歉。我离开电话了。或者我的耳机断开了，或者我不小心按了静音。这就是我尽量做的——30秒。
North Adams Public Safety. This line is recorded.
北亚当斯公共安全中心。此线路已被录音。
1251 from North 911, transferring a operator from the Overdose Prevention Crisis Line, requesting ambulance in North Adams, Massachusetts. I have the address of [BEEPED], Apartment 1, upstairs.
1251号呼叫北亚当斯911，正在转接“用药过量预防危机热线”的接线员，请求在马萨诸塞州北亚当斯市派遣救护车。我有地址[哔声]，1号公寓，楼上。
What's the nature of the request?
请求的性质是什么？
The caller became unresponsive while on the line with me.
来电者在与我通话时失去了反应。
OK, do you have any reason to believe they may have taken any narcotics?
好的，你有理由相信他们可能服用了任何毒品吗？
We're an overdose crisis line, so it's possible.
我们是一条药物过量危机热线，所以有可能。
OK, ma'am, can you give me any specifics in terms of the age of the potential patient?
好的，女士，你能提供任何关于潜在患者年龄的具体信息吗？
It's a female. Her first name is Kimber, K-I-M-B-E-R.
是位女性。她的名字叫金伯，K-I-M-B-E-R。
We're going to get help en route, ma'am. If you happen to get them back on the line or gain anything further, please call us right back, OK?
我们会安排救援人员赶往现场，女士。如果您碰巧让他们重新上线或获得了进一步情况，请立即打回给我们，好吗？
OK, yeah, I've got the call merged in. Yeah.
好的，是的，我已经合并了通话。是的。
OK, can you hear anything in the background, ma'am?
好的，女士，你能听到背景里有什么声音吗？
No, no.
没有，没有。
I'm not picking anything up on my end.
我这边什么都没听到。
No, let me call her name again. Kimber? Baby, answer me. Kimber? No.
没有，让我再叫一次她的名字。金伯？亲爱的，回答我。金伯？没有。
OK, I'm going to get multiple agencies en route to assist, OK?
好的，我会派遣多个部门前往协助，好吗？
OK, her front door is unlocked.
好的，她的前门没锁。
OK, thank you for letting us know.
好的，谢谢你告诉我们。
All right, OK.
好的，好的。
Bye.
再见。
Kimber, baby, I got you some help coming.
金伯，亲爱的，我叫了人来救你。
Jessie stays on the line. And then after a little while, you can faintly hear in the background, over the phone, someone shouting, "Anybody home"?
杰西一直保持着通话。过了一会儿，你可以模糊地听到背景里，通过电话，有人在喊，“有人在家吗”？
Anybody home?
有人在家吗？
The ambulance got there just 3 and 1/2 minutes after Jessie disconnected from 911.
救护车在杰西挂断911电话后仅3分半钟就到达了。
You awake?
你醒着吗？
Jessie hears him say, "You awake"? Then, "move that suitcase."
杰西听到他说，“你醒着吗？”然后，“把那个手提箱移开”。
Move that suitcase.
把那个手提箱移开。
And then she hangs up.
然后她挂断了电话。
It's easy to read the statistics and still not be able to imagine what the overdose crisis looks like in this country. More than 100,000 people die from an overdose each year. That means that Americans are now more likely to die from an overdose than from a car accident. This hotline's purpose is simple and very single-minded. It's not to get people sober or push them into treatment. It's just to keep people alive, one injection or snort after another.
很容易读到统计数据却仍然无法想象这个国家的药物过量危机是什么样子。每年有超过10万人死于药物过量。这意味着美国人现在死于药物过量的可能性比死于车祸还要大。这条热线的目的很简单，非常专一。它不是为了让人们戒毒或强迫他们接受治疗。它只是为了让人们活下去，一次注射，一次吸食之后，还能继续活下去。
I wanted to know what it was like for everyone, the callers and the people like Jessie, who sit there while someone uses, knowing they could die right there on the phone. Jessie talks to people week after week, and sometimes they just stop calling. Maybe it's because they're not using anymore. Maybe it's because they're gone.
我想知道每个人的感受是怎样的，包括那些打电话的人，以及像杰西这样的人，他们在别人吸毒时守在电话旁，知道他们可能会当场死在电话那一头。杰西每周都在与人交谈，有时他们就不再打电话了。也许是因为他们不再用了。也许是因为他们已经不在了。
Actual overdoses on the hotline don't happen that often. And Jessie had no way to know what went on after she hung up that day with Kimber. She kept answering calls on the line, tried to distract herself. She says she probably walked around her yard, poured herself a Sprite. Then she got a text from a pretty close friend of hers, a guy named Stephen. He's a paramedic, so he sees a lot of overdoses. She has him in her phone as "Bruh."
热线上实际的过量用药事件并不常见。杰西没有办法知道那天和金伯挂断电话后发生了什么。她继续回答线上的电话，试图转移自己的注意力。她说她可能在院子里走来走去，给自己倒了一杯雪碧。然后她收到了一个相当亲近的朋友的短信，一个叫斯蒂芬的家伙。他是名医护人员，所以他见过很多用药过量的情况。她在手机里把他存为“兄弟”（Bruh）。
He said, what up, homie? I said, I was just living the dream, taking some calls, some NUA calls. What you doing? He said, oh, you know I'm at work today, right? And I'm like, oh, I forgot today's Saturday.
他说，怎么了，伙计？我说，我只是在过梦想中的生活，接些电话，一些NUA的电话。你在干嘛？他说，哦，你知道我今天在上班吧？我说，哦，我忘了今天是星期六。
Stephen works in Massachusetts.
斯蒂芬在马萨诸塞州工作。
Texting back and forth, and I was like, oh, yeah, I had a Never Use Alone call. I had an overdose call in Massachusetts today.
发来发去短信，我就说，哦，是的，我今天有个“绝不独自使用”的电话。我在马萨诸塞州有个过量用药的电话。
Immediately, her phone rings. It's him. Like, instead of texting, he wants to talk. She answers.
她的电话立刻响了。是他打来的。他不想发短信，想聊聊。她接听了。
He said, where? I said, hold on. I don't remember. He said, bitch, where? I said, bitch, I said hold on. I got to go get the book. Damn. I open the book. North Adams, Massachusetts. The sob that left this man's chest, I'll never forget. He said that was me.
他说，在哪？我说，等等。我不记得了。他说，婊子，在哪？我说，婊子，我说了等一下。我得去拿本子。该死。我打开本子。马萨诸塞州北亚当斯。那个男人胸腔里发出的啜泣声，我永远不会忘记。他说那是我。
Act 2, Stephen. Stephen Murray, the paramedic who responded to that overdose call Jessie took, he had a lot of jobs before working in an ambulance, each with a very different uniform. The first was a black t-shirt. He was in a metal band. Then a suit and tie. When he was in college, he ran for a seat on the village council and won. Being a paramedic meant wearing a button-up with S. Murray on one pocket and a badge above the other. He carried his dispatch radio pretty much everywhere, which is how he got the call that day.
第二幕，斯蒂芬。斯蒂芬·默里，那位响应杰西接到的过量用药电话的医护人员，他在在救护车工作之前做过很多工作，每一份工作都有非常不同的制服。第一件是一件黑色T恤。他在一个金属乐队里。然后是西装和领带。他在大学时，竞选过乡村议会的席位并赢得了选举。作为一名医护人员意味着穿着一件口袋上写着“S. 默里”，上面有徽章的衬衫。他基本上随身带着调度电台，这就是他那天接到电话的方式。
So it came in as an unresponsive possible overdose. That's all we really got. And when I heard the address, I was like, oh, that's really close by.
当时接到的通知是“失去反应，可能的药物过量”。这就是我们真正得到的所有信息。当我听到地址时，我想，哦，那非常近。
It was right up the hill from the ambulance station, basically on the same street.
它就在救护站上方的小山上，基本上在同一条街上。
We're only like 0.4, 0.5 miles away. So I like jump in.
我们离那儿只有0.4或0.5英里。所以我跳上车。
How many people?
多少人？
It was one engine company, three police cruisers, and two ambulances. We get there, and I'm looking at the building, and there's multiple units within this big house.
是一辆消防车、三辆警车和两辆救护车。我们到达那里时，我看着那栋楼，这个大房子里有多个单元。
He bangs on the door, doesn't hear anything. Then he sees a little stairway, runs up, finds another door, which is unlocked. He lets himself in.
他敲门，没听到任何声音。然后他看到一个小楼梯，跑上去，发现另一扇没锁的门。他自己走了进去。
I'm like, hello? Anybody here? Like, EMS. With the cops there behind me, they're yelling out, and I'm looking around. And I get down this hallway.
我喊道，有人吗？有人在吗？急救人员。警察跟在后面，他们也在呼喊，我四处张望。我顺着这条走廊走过去。
At the end, there's a little bathroom.
在尽头有一个小浴室。
And I find a girl laying on the ground, or a woman laying on the ground. But she's very small, and she looked really young. And she was blue. And so I was like, crap.
我发现一个女孩躺在地上，或者一个女人躺在地上。但她非常瘦小，看起来非常年轻。而且她是青紫色的。所以我当时就想，糟了。
Why? Hold it. Why?
为什么？等等。为什么？
Well, because nobody's there, and she's blue. When someone's blue, I know they're not breathing.
嗯，因为那里没有人，而且她是青紫色的。当一个人发青时，我知道她没在呼吸了。
You thought you were too late.
你以为你太迟了。
Yeah, that's where my mind went immediately was that, here's somebody who's alone. She's blue on the ground. And I find her pulse, and it's quite slow. So it's like in the 40s. So I turned to the cop and said, she's got a pulse. The bathroom is quite small, though, and I am big. And it's really hard to work on somebody when you can't kneel down next to them.
是的，我脑子里立刻闪过的就是，这有一个人孤身一人。她发青倒在地上。我摸了摸她的脉搏，它非常微弱。大概每分钟40次。所以我转向警察说，她有脉搏。不过浴室很小，而我个子很大。当你不能跪在她旁边工作时，要对一个人进行急救真的很困难。
And so I put my arms under hers and I drag her into the living room, down the hallway to the living room. And at that point, the rest of my crew had brought all of our equipment upstairs. So they were like-- they came up and put down our bag next to me.
所以我把胳膊伸到她腋下，把她拖到客厅，顺着走廊拖到客厅。那时，我的其余队员已经把我们所有的设备带上来了。所以他们——他们上来，把包放在我旁边。
If they'd gotten there a few minutes later, it might have been too late. But now they had a chance. Stephen's got a particular way he likes to handle overdoses, that he feels is easier on the people being revived. Because-- he's thought about this a lot-- if they do come to, it's going to be a very strange experience, some random guy leaning over you, face upside down.
如果他们晚到几分钟，可能就太迟了。但现在他们还有机会。斯蒂芬处理过量用药有自己特别的方式，他觉得这对被抢救的人来说更容易接受。因为——他对此思考了很多——如果他们真的清醒过来，那将是一种非常奇怪的体验，一个陌生人俯身在你上方，脸是倒过来的。
And if you just give someone a big dose of Narcan, it'll throw them into withdrawal. People sometimes wake up angry. They'll have a massive headache because they might not have been getting oxygen to their brain. That lack of oxygen, that's what will kill you in an overdose. So Stephen starts by fixing that.
而且如果你给一个人大剂量的纳洛酮，这会让他们陷入戒断反应。人们有时醒来会很生气。他们会剧烈头痛，因为他们的大脑可能没有得到氧气。那种缺氧才是药物过量致死的原因。所以斯蒂芬先从解决这个问题开始。
So I grabbed the bag valve mask out, hooked up to oxygen, and start to breathe for her. And in the meantime, I directed one of my staff members to draw me up-- to pull out Narcan and put a needle on it, because I like to give it intramuscularly because I can control the dose better.
所以我拿出了球囊面罩，连上氧气，开始为她呼吸。与此同时，我指挥我的队员为我抽取——取出纳洛酮并装上针头，因为我喜欢肌内注射，这样我可以更好地控制剂量。
He has the police stand in another room while he works.
他让警察站在另一个房间，自己开始工作。
Well, because the thing is, I've seen people come out and vomit and feel unwell. And when I first started EMS, I remember the police would be standing over them, like what did you use, like yelling at them. I started to think about, like, what is that environment like when they wake up? If there are too many people in the room, I will tell people to go wait outside.
嗯，因为问题是，我见过人们苏醒后呕吐并感到不适。当我刚开始做急救时，我记得警察会站在他们上方，比如“你用了什么”，对着他们大喊大叫。我开始思考，当他们醒来时，那样的环境是什么样的？如果房间里人太多，我会叫人们去外面等。
So Stephen's kneeling over Kimber's head, squeezing oxygen into her lungs, one breath at a time. Then he gives her the smallest dose of naloxone, just to see how she'll react.
所以斯蒂芬跪在金伯的头部上方，一次一次地把氧气挤进她的肺里。然后他给她注射了极小剂量的纳洛酮，看看她会有什么反应。
Her color improves. Her oxygen saturation comes up. And she then wakes up.
她的肤色好转了。她的血氧饱和度上升了。然后她醒了过来。
Do you remember what she said to you?
你记得她对你说了什么吗？
She looked upset.
她看起来很心烦。
Upset, despite all his effort, but alive. There's a conversation Stephen sometimes has with people he's revived. He doesn't remember where it happened with Kimber, but often, it's in the back of the ambulance where the driver can't hear. The patient will say something like, you're so much nicer than the other EMTs. And then Stephen will explain, I've been in your shoes.
心烦，尽管他付出了所有努力，但她活着。斯蒂芬有时会和他抢救过来的人进行一次谈话。他不记得在金伯身上发生在哪里，但通常是在救护车后面，司机听不到的地方。病人会说类似“你比其他急救员友好多了”的话。然后斯蒂芬会解释说，我也曾经处于你的位置。
So Stephen, the person who revived Kimber from her overdose, he'd also survived an overdose. Let me tell you what happened. Stephen started using drugs sometime after he stopped touring with that metal band. He'd been straight edge then, so no alcohol, no drugs. But then he went to college, University of Miami, and academics had never been his thing.
所以斯蒂芬，那个从药物过量中抢救了金伯的人，他也曾经在过量用药中幸存下来。让我告诉你发生了什么。斯蒂芬是在停止随那个金属乐队巡演后开始使用药物的。那时候他是“直刃族”（straight edge），不喝酒、不嗑药。但后来他上了大学，迈阿密大学，而学术从来不是他的强项。
The people that I fell in with, my group of friends, we all met at the tables that were outside the dorms. And we would smoke cigarettes outside. It was like this thing. And the guy that used to sell us our weed, he was great. He was just like this really cool-- I can't even describe him. He was like-- he would show up with a fishing tackle box full of drugs. It was like a menu, right? And he knew that I had been struggling a bit.
我结交的人，我的朋友群体，我们都是在宿舍外的桌子上认识的。我们会在外面抽烟。就是那种事。卖给我们大麻的那个家伙，他很棒。他就像是个非常酷的——我甚至没法形容他。他就像是——他会带着一个装满毒品的钓具盒出现。这就像一份菜单，对吧？而且他知道我当时有点挣扎。
A friend of the group named Kelly had died recently. She'd fallen off a balcony. It really kind of rocked Stephen's world.
我们组里一个叫凯莉的朋友最近去世了。她从阳台上掉了下来。这真的动摇了斯蒂芬的世界。
And so he was like, oh, if I remember right-- he was like, oh, you should try these. It will make you feel better. And that was like oxycodone.
所以他说，哦，如果我没记错的话——他说，哦，你应该试试这个。它会让你感觉好点。那就是羟考酮。
So drugs became part of Stephen's very busy life. He's going to school, working a campus job. He'd also won that seat on the local village council.
所以毒品成了斯蒂芬忙碌生活的一部分。他要去上学，做一份校园工作。他甚至赢得了那个地方乡村议会的席位。
At the time, they were saying I was the youngest elected official that had ever happened in South Florida. I don't know if that's like verifiable, but that's what people were saying about me. And here I am, using drugs the whole time.
当时，他们说我是南佛罗里达州有史以来最年轻的民选官员。我不知道这是否可核实，但人们就是这么说我的。而我，一直在用药。
He used in his car before talking to TV news. Before bed, he would lay out lines of oxy for when he woke up at night in withdrawal. It was the only way he'd get back to sleep. And he was getting way too skinny.
我在和电视新闻连线前会在车里吸食。睡前，他会摆好羟考酮的药线，以便半夜戒断醒来时使用。那是他唯一能再次入睡的方式。而且他变得太瘦了。
I used to wear baggier clothes when I would talk to my parents. This is the era when Skype was a thing. And I used to put under-eye concealer on my eyes. I have naturally dark circles under my eyes. But because I had lost so much weight, it was so sunken in. They were very like pronounced. And so I would put under-eye concealer on before I would go on camera with my parents.
我和父母交谈时，我会穿比较宽松的衣服。那是Skype流行的时代。我会在眼睛下面涂遮瑕膏。我的眼睛下面天生有黑眼圈。但因为我瘦了太多，眼窝深陷。它们看起来非常明显。所以我会在和父母视频连线前涂上眼下遮瑕膏。
Wow.
哇。
And actually, the camera would be faced backward, where I had all of my accolades on the wall, like certificate of election from the Board of Elections. And I got a letter from a congressman congratulating me on being elected. And just those sorts of things were behind me. But on the other side of the camera, my life was chaos. So, yeah.
事实上，相机会对着后面，墙上挂着我的所有荣誉，比如选举委员会颁发的当选证书。我还收到了一封国会议员写给我的信，祝贺我当选。这些东西就在我身后。但在摄像头的另一边，我的生活是一团糟。所以，是的。
Stephen thinks he probably OD'd twice somewhere in there, but luckily, he came to on his own. None of that stopped him. His family, at some point, had an intervention, which he said you could see a mile away. Like, he walked into the room, and everyone was sitting there, and no one was saying anything. And he was like, oh, I know what this is.
斯蒂芬认为他大概在那期间过量用药两次，但幸运的是，他自己醒了过来。所有这些都没能阻止他。他的家人在某个时候进行了一次干预，他说你隔着一英里都能看出来。就像，他走进房间，每个人都坐在那里，没人说话。他就想，哦，我知道这是什么。
But he felt relieved to be found out. He only had to go to rehab once, but recovery was a long process. Stephen tried various jobs, ran out of money, went back to living with his folks. They were retired in Western Massachusetts, where he noticed they were looking for volunteer firefighters. So he signed up. And for some reason, it stuck.
但他感到被发现后如释重负。他只去过一次康复中心，但康复是一个漫长的过程。斯蒂芬尝试了各种工作，花光了钱，又回去和父母住在一起。他们在马萨诸塞州西部退休了，他注意到他们正在招募志愿消防员。所以他报了名。出于某种原因，他留下了。
In my head and in my mind, I'm like, I'm Stephen the addict. And now, I'm Stephen the firefighter. And it was like, I'm a firefighter. That's pretty cool.
在我的头脑和思想里，我心想，我是斯蒂芬，瘾君子。现在，我是斯蒂芬，消防员。感觉就像，我是个消防员。那很酷。
Eventually, he became a paramedic. Stephen's experience with addiction is not what made saving Kimber so emotional for him though. It was something else. Back when Stephen was using, his drugs were coming from pain clinics known as pill mills. But by the time he became a paramedic, many of those had been shut down.
最终，他成为了一名医护人员。斯蒂芬对成瘾的亲身经历并不是让挽救金伯变得如此情绪化的原因。还有别的原因。当斯蒂芬在吸毒时，他的药来自于被称为“药厂”（pill mills）的疼痛诊所。但当他成为医护人员时，很多药厂已经被关闭了。
More and more people were getting drugs off the street. That's when fentanyl entered the scene. Fentanyl can be 50 times stronger than heroin. It was causing these cluster overdoses. Stephen would see them from his ambulance. He'd have days where he'd go to five ODs, one after another. He was seeing more people die too. One case stuck with him. Everything went wrong. They were at the station when he got the call.
越来越多的人开始从街上买药。就在那时，芬太尼进入了现场。芬太尼的药力可能比海洛因强50倍。它导致了这些集群式的药物过量事件。斯蒂芬会在救护车里看到它们。他曾有连续一天出诊五次药物过量的经历。他也看到更多人死去。有一个案例一直萦绕在他心头。一切都出错了。接到电话时他们正在站里。
And the street address that was given, we'll say, for example, that was 313, like 3-1-3. And we get there, and there is no 313.
给出的街道地址，我们假设，是313，3-1-3。我们到了那里，没有313。
This isn't that uncommon, but usually, someone hears the sirens and comes out, says, we're over here.
这并不罕见，但通常人们会听到警报声出来说，我们在这儿。
And so in this particular case, that didn't happen. And so we just start to go knock on doors and look. And so that went on. We knocked out a bunch of doors, and nobody ever came out. And so the other thing that dispatch will try to do is they'll try to call the person back repeatedly. Nobody answered on the call back. And so, eventually, we have finite resources. And so the next calls are coming in, and we have to move on.
在这个特殊案例中，这没发生。所以我们开始去敲门寻找。那一阵子，我们敲了一堆门，从来没人出来。调度中心会尝试反复回拨电话。没人接听。所以，最终，我们的资源是有限的。下一个电话进来了，我们不得不离开。
A little while later, a different call comes in, a call about a dead body, a woman. Stephen hears the location and realizes this was the overdose victim from that original call. In fact, Stephen had knocked on her very door. Whoever called 911 the first time, they'd mixed up the numbers. So it wasn't 313. It was 133, something like that. So when Stephen and the cops fanned out, went house to house, Stephen had craned his neck to look in the window of the right building, but he just couldn't see the woman who needed his help. She was just out of view.
不久后，另一个电话进来了，关于一具尸体，一个女人。斯蒂芬听到地点意识到这就是那个原始电话里的过量用药受害者。事实上，斯蒂芬敲过她的门。无论谁第一次拨打911，他们弄错了数字。所以不是313。是133，类似这样。所以当斯蒂芬和警察散开，挨家挨户敲门时，斯蒂芬曾探头往那栋正确建筑的窗户里看，但他就是没看到那个需要他帮助的女人。她正好在视野之外。
She was right around the corner from the door that I had looked in. And I just thought to myself, I was like six feet from her. And when I got there, she was probably-- we could still have saved her. That was actually somebody that I had reversed an overdose on in the past. I hadn't stayed in real touch, but she worked in the community, so I would see her sometimes.
她就在我探头看的那扇门拐角处。我当时心想，我离她只有六英尺远。当我们到达时，她可能——我们本可以救她的。那其实是我过去曾挽救过的一次药物过量的对象。我没跟她保持密切联系，但她在社区里工作，所以有时我会见到她。
Stephen played this over and over again in his mind, looking for ways it could have gone differently. He understood that whoever called 911, they were doing what they could to keep this woman alive, but they were also scared, scared that when someone like Stephen showed up, there would be trouble. So they left. And in the end, it was leaving this woman alone that killed her. It meant Stephen couldn't find her. That overdose call solidified something for Stephen.
斯蒂芬在脑海里反复重演这一幕，寻找可能发生不同结果的途径。他明白无论谁打了911，他们都在尽其所能让那个女人活下去，但他们也害怕，害怕像斯蒂芬这样的人出现会带来麻烦。所以他们离开了。最终，留下那个女人独自一人害了她。这意味着斯蒂芬没能找到她。那次过量用药的电话对斯蒂芬巩固了一些东西。
With the drug supply getting more dangerous, keeping people who used drugs safe meant making sure they weren't left by themselves. It was sometime around then that he heard about the Never Use Alone hotline, and it immediately made sense. So he got involved-- Zoom meetings, stuff like that. That's how he met Jessie. To get the word out where he was, he made these little cards.
随着毒品供应变得更加危险，确保那些使用毒品的人的安全意味着确保他们不会被单独留下。大约就在那时，他听说“绝不独自使用”热线，这立刻说得通了。所以他参与进来了——Zoom会议，之类的东西。他就是那样认识杰西的。为了在他所在的地方宣传，他制作了这些小卡片。
I made this simple design on Vistaprint. And I'm not a web designer or a graphic designer, so it looks terrible. But basically, it was like, this is the Massachusetts line. Here's the number. This is what we do. And so I used my credit card and bought like 5,000 of those.
我在Vistaprint上做了这个简单的设计。我不是网页设计师或平面设计师，所以它看起来很糟糕。但基本上，它就像，这是马萨诸塞州热线。电话号码是这个。这就是我们做的。所以我用了我的信用卡买了5000张。
He convinced programs that give out clean syringes to include these Never Use Alone cards in their kits. Stephen had no idea if any of this was really working. A lot of times, he'd talked to drug users who said, what? I'm going to call up some stranger, tell them I'm about to inject dope? Are you kidding?
他劝说分发清洁注射器的项目将这些“绝不独自使用”卡片包含在他们的工具包中。斯蒂芬根本不知道这些是否有用。很多时候，他与吸毒者交谈，他们说，什么？我要打给某个陌生人，告诉他我要注射毒品？你在开玩笑吗？
But a few hours before he revived Kimber, she had gotten one of these cards bundled up with the stuff she'd picked up at a needle exchange. That was why she called. That was the thing that saved her life. Stephen didn't know that though. When he dragged her out of the bathroom that day and started giving her rescue breaths, there was a cell phone right next to her. He just didn't put two and two together.
但在他抢救金伯前几个小时，她刚好在针头交换点领到的东西里捆绑了一张这样的卡片。这就是她打电话的原因。那就是挽救她生命的东西。但斯蒂芬不知道。那天他把她从浴室拖出来，开始给她人工呼吸时，她旁边就有一部手机。他只是没把这两者联系起来。
After Kimber opened her eyes, Stephen told her she had to go to the hospital for observation. That meant she had to do this walk of shame down her front steps and climb into the back of the ambulance. It was nearly summer, but she put on a big winter coat, pulled up the hood. Stephen started packing up. Before he left the scene, he went to check in with his crew.
在金伯睁开眼睛后，斯蒂芬告诉她必须去医院观察。这意味着她必须走下前台阶，爬进救护车后座，经历那样的“羞辱之旅”。当时快夏天了，但她穿了一件厚厚的冬装，拉上了兜帽。斯蒂芬开始收拾东西。在离开现场前，他去和他的队员确认情况。
So they had the back doors of the ambulance open. And I stepped up into the back to talk to them. And it dawned on me again, like, oh, she was alone. So I said something along the lines of like, whoever was here with you called and left. You need to tell them never to do that again. They need to stay with you until we get here. And then she said, I wasn't with anybody. I was alone. And then I said, well, then, who called 911? And then she said, I called the Never Use Alone hotline.
救护车后门开着。我跨进后面和他们说话。我再次意识到，哦，她是一个人。所以我说类似“和你在一起的人打了电话后离开了。你需要告诉他们永远不要再那样做了。他们需要陪着你直到我们赶到。”然后她说，“我没和任何人在一起。我是一个人。”然后我说，“那谁打了911？”她说，“我打了‘绝不独自使用’热线。”
"Oh, my God," he thought. When he got back to the station, that's when he started texting Jessie, and that's when it all kind of came out of him.
“天哪，”他想。回到站里时，他开始给杰西发短信，事情真相大白。
When she told me that she was the operator, I started crying. I couldn't believe it. We sobbed on the phone together. I was in my office. There was this conference room thing that I was in, and I had the door closed. And I was talking to her, and I'm sitting there crying with her. And it was just-- it was like, wow.
当她告诉我她是接线员时，我哭了。我简直不敢相信。我们在电话里一起啜泣。我在我的办公室。我在一个会议室里，把门关上了。我跟她说着话，坐在那儿和她一起哭。那简直——感觉像，哇。
Stephen says, over his time as a paramedic, he pronounced maybe 30 people dead from an overdose. All of them were alone. Kimber was alone too, but she had the line. The line had worked. It's so rare to find something that actually protects people once they're dealing with an addiction. But even when you save someone from an overdose, it doesn't mean they'll stop using. In fact, usually, they don't.
斯蒂芬说，在他做医护人员的时间里，他宣布了大约30人死于药物过量。他们全部都是孤身一人。金伯也是孤身一人，但她有这条热线。这条热线发挥了作用。找到真正能保护人们对抗成瘾的东西是如此罕见。但即使你从过量用药中挽救了一个人，也不意味着他们会停止使用。事实上，通常他们不会。
The morning after Stephen revived Kimber, Jessie sent her a text. "Hi," she wrote. "I am so thankful you called." She sent this with a little smiley face and a green heart emoji. Within a couple of hours, Kimber wrote back. She thanked Jessie, asked how many times she got Narcanned. Then, Kimber says, "I want to use again this morning, but I'm terrified." "If you use again today," Jessie replied, "the likelihood of you OD'ing again is almost guaranteed."
斯蒂芬抢救金伯后的第二天早上，杰西发了条短信。“嗨，”她写道。“我非常感谢你打了电话。”她发了这个短信，带了一个小笑脸和一个绿色心形表情符号。几个小时内，金伯回信了。她感谢了杰西，问自己被用了几次纳洛酮。然后，金伯说，“我想今天早上再用一次，但我很害怕。”“如果你今天再用，”杰西回复，“你再次过量用药的可能性几乎是百分之百。”
Mary Harris. Coming up, what's Jessie's deal? Also, a fight in a Krispy Kreme parking lot. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
玛丽·哈里斯。接下来，杰西的故事是什么？还有，克里斯皮奶油甜甜圈停车场里的一场打斗。那是芝加哥公共广播电台节目继续后的内容。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, "The Call," the story of one phone call to one telephone hotline and its aftermath. So Kimber did keep using and kept calling the line. And a lot of times, she was connected with Jessie, which brings us to Act 3 of our program, "Jessie." Again, here's Mary Harris.
这里是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“那通电话”，关于拨打某条电话热线及后续影响的故事。金伯确实继续使用并一直拨打热线。很多时候，她是被转接到杰西这里的，这就引出了我们节目的第三幕，“杰西”。再次有请玛丽·哈里斯。
Jessie's kind of the backstop for the entire hotline, the whole operation. If none of the other operators are available, the calls automatically go to her. And she pretty much always picks up. Sometimes she'll even give someone her cell and say, just call me directly. She did that with Kimber. It's like she can't help herself.
杰西算是整个热线、整个行动的最后防线。如果没有其他接线员有空，电话会自动转到她那里。而且她几乎总是接听。有时她甚至会把自己的手机号给别人说，直接打给我。她对金伯就是这么做的。感觉她控制不住自己。
Oh, I got a call. OK.
哦，我有电话。好的。
I went down to visit Jessie at her home in Georgia to watch her work.
我去杰西在乔治亚州的家中拜访她，观察她工作。
You have an incoming call.
有你的呼入电话。
Never Use Alone. It's Jessie.
“绝不独自使用”，我是杰西。
From the second I walked in, she was taking calls, still in her housedress and mismatched socks. The vibe was organized chaos. She takes in strays, seven cats-- one is missing an eye-- a chihuahua, and more chickens than she can count.
从我走进去的那一秒起，她就在接电话，还穿着居家服和不搭调的袜子。氛围是“有组织的混乱”。她收留流浪动物，七只猫——其中一只少了一只眼睛——一只吉娃娃，还有数不清的鸡。
Look at our eggs.
看看我们的蛋。
Eh! Oh, those are from your chickens?
额！哦，那些是你养的鸡下的吗？
Yes, those are the eating eggs. We've got eating eggs.
是的，那些是食用的蛋。我们有食用的蛋。
They laid their eggs in the garage. I wanted to know how Jessie, a nurse, had ended up spending so much of her time on this line. And at some point, in a pause in the conversation, she said this.
它们在车库里下了蛋。我想知道作为护士的杰西，为何最终将如此多的时间花在这条热线上。在谈话的某个间隙，她说了这个。
My child has called this line before.
我的孩子以前也打过这条热线。
She was talking about Kaylen. Kaylen's 23, her only kid.
她在谈论凯伦。凯伦23岁，她唯一的孩子。
She's the most magnificent creature I've ever met in my life. She's also the raggediest bitch I've ever met in my life. She's magnificent. She is magnificent.
她是我一生中见过的最壮丽的生物。她也是我一生中见过的最烂的婊子。她很壮丽。她真的很壮丽。
Kaylen has overdosed a dozen times and counting.
凯伦已经过量用药十几次，而且还在增加。
Have you picked up the phone and it's your daughter?
你接过电话发现是你的女儿吗？
No, she would let me know that she was calling. "Hey, Mom, I'm going to call the line." Thanks for letting me know. I think-- I know that I could cut it off. I could cut the Mama off. I could keep the Mama cut off if she become unresponsive. I know I could do what I have to do. But what if I couldn't?
不，她会让我知道她在打电话。“嘿，妈妈，我要打热线了。”谢谢你告诉我。我想——我知道我可以切断它。我可以切断“妈妈”这个角色。如果她变得没反应，我可以保持“妈妈”这一面不参与。我知道我可以做我必须做的事。但如果我做不到呢？
Watching her daughter nearly die again and again is kind of how Jessie came around to a whole new way of thinking, and the hotline, too. She tried for years to force her daughter to change. She wanted her to finish school. She wanted her to go to rehab. She wanted her to come home. But wanting all that never made anything go differently. It just made Kaylen push her away.
看着自己的女儿一次又一次濒临死亡，这就是杰西产生全新思维方式的方式，热线也是如此。她多年来一直试图强迫女儿改变。她希望她完成学业。她希望她去戒毒。她希望她回家。但想要这一切从未改变任何事情。这只会让凯伦把她推开。
Now, for her daughter, she really only has one goal. It's the same goal she has for her callers-- don't die. Jessie's serious about this goal, and this one goal only. She literally has a tattoo on her forearm that's a bird taking flight. It's carrying a banner in its beak with a single word on it, "fucks," as in, "I don't give a fuck." My fucks are flying away.
现在，对女儿，她其实只有一个目标。这和她对来电者的目标一样——别死。杰西对这个目标非常认真，而且只有这一个目标。她的前臂上甚至纹着一只飞翔的鸟。它喙里衔着一条横幅，上面写着一个词，“管他的”（fucks），意思是，“我不在乎”（I don't give a fuck）。我的“在乎”正在飞走。
Jessie told me this one story about a time Kaylen pulled up in front of the house with a bag of dope and a couple of friends. It was late at night, just Jessie and her husband at home. Kaylen called her from the driveway.
杰西告诉了我一个关于凯伦有次载着一袋毒品和几个朋友开到家门口的故事。那是深夜，家里只有杰西和她丈夫。凯伦在车道上给她打了电话。
I said, what are y'all doing? She said, well, Mama, we just picked up from a new guy, and we're not real sure if it's safe or not. I said, so y'all are going to sit in my front yard and use dope in a car? I said, how the hell-- I said, what I'm gonna do for y'all in a car, Kaylen? And I heard her. She said, I told y'all we could go inside. I said, yes. I said, you're either going to come inside, or you're going to get out of my yard. I said I can't--
我说，你们在干什么？她说，嗯，妈妈，我们刚从一个新家伙那儿拿了货，不确定这东西安全不安全。我说，所以你们打算坐在我前院的车里吸毒？我说，这到底——我说，凯伦，在车里我能为你们做什么？我听到了她的声音。她说，我告诉你们我们可以进屋。我说，是的。我说，要么进屋，要么滚出我的院子。我说我不能——
Her friends didn't believe her.
她的朋友们不相信她。
Mm-mm.
嗯嗯。
They came in, and she watched as her daughter injected herself at her kitchen table. I had so many questions about this approach. I'm a parent. I know how hard it is to stop wanting things for your kids, stop protecting them, stop pushing them towards some imagined, better future. The implications of abandoning that wanting were so radical to me. I asked, what if Kaylen never stops using drugs?
他们进来了，她看着女儿在自己的餐桌旁给自己注射。我对这种方法有很多疑问。我是个家长。我知道停止对孩子抱有期望、停止保护他们、停止把他们推向某种想象中的美好未来是多么困难。放弃这种“期望”的含义对我来说太激进了。我问，如果凯伦永远不停止用药怎么办？
If what she wants to do is continue to use, she should be alive and healthy to do so. If what she wants to do is one day kick and go on and do something else, she should be healthy and alive to be able to do so.
如果她想做的是继续使用，她应该活得健康，这样才能继续。如果她有一天想戒掉并去做别的事，她应该健康地活着，这样才能做到。
Do you even see her like no longer using permanently as a goal?
你甚至把她“永久不再使用”视为一个目标吗？
I don't know. I honestly don't think about what Kaylen will or won't do, and I honestly don't-- I don't mean this to sound like it's going to sound-- I really don't care what Kaylen does. As long as she don't die, that'll be great. That's it. We can work with anything but death.
我不知道。老实说，我不去想凯伦会做什么或不会做什么，而且我老实说——我不是说这听起来很糟糕——我真的不在乎凯伦做什么。只要她不死，那就太好了。就是这样。除了死亡，我们可以应付任何事情。
It must have taken you so long to get there.
你一定花了很长时间才达到这种心态。
It took a fight in a Krispy Kreme parking lot one morning, right there where y'all stay. You go down to the end of Dawson. I bet y'all go to the end of Dawson and take a left to come to my house. It's a Krispy Kreme donut shop right there. It took a fist fight in the Krispy Kreme parking lot for me and her to come to this place.
这是一天早上在克里斯皮奶油甜甜圈停车场的一场打斗带来的，就在你们住的地方附近。你们去道森路的尽头，我敢打赌你们会在那儿左转来我家。那里有个克里斯皮奶油甜甜圈店。那是克里斯皮奶油停车场的一场拳架，才让我和她走到了这一步。
What happened? What was it over?
发生了什么？是为了什么打架？
I hadn't seen her in weeks. I hadn't heard from her. She was hiding from me. Because every time I talked to her, I was giving her the business, you know? You're going to come home. You're going to do this. You're going do that. I was yelling at her, making her feel like crap. People who are using substances who are in the place that she is, they feel bad enough about themselves. They don't need us to help them. OK?
我有几周没见到她了。我没听到过她的消息。她在躲着我。因为每次我跟她说话，我都在说教，你知道吗？你要回家。你要做这个。你要做那个。我在对她大喊大叫，让她感觉自己很烂。那些正在用药、处于她这种状态的人，他们对自己已经够难受了。不需要我们去帮他们。好吗？
So she would change her phone number. She would hide from me. I wouldn't see her. I'd ride an hour every morning before work. I'd ride an hour at lunch. And I'd ride an hour and a half every afternoon when I got off. I would ride 3 and 1/2 hours every single day, Monday through Friday, to try to catch a glimpse of my baby.
所以她会换手机号。她会躲着我。我见不到她。我每天上班前开车一小时。午饭时开车一小时。下班后下午又开一个半小时。我每天，周一到周五，都会开车3个半小时，试图捕捉我宝贝的一瞥。
You would just literally ride around town, looking for her?
你真的就是在城里开车，到处找她？
Literally ride around town in the places that I knew she was, trying to catch a glimpse of my baby. One morning, on the way to work, I saw her. She doesn't remember this. She was that altered. But I saw her walking across the Krispy Kreme parking lot, and I drove across five lanes of traffic, me in that little Jeep.
真的就是在城里我知道她会去的地方转悠，试图捕捉我宝贝的一瞥。一天早上，上班路上，我看到了她。她不记得这回事了。她当时神志太模糊了。但我看到她穿过克里斯皮奶油甜甜圈停车场，我开着那辆小吉普车穿过了五条车道。
And I ran up on her, and I was excited. And I guess I ran up real fast. And she had her earbuds in, and I touched her. I grabbed her shoulder. I meant to touch her shoulder, but I grabbed her shoulder. And when I did, she turned around and hit me. And being from West Tennessee, I hit her back. So for a few seconds, she forgot I was her mama, and I forgot I was her mama. And when we got through fighting in the Krispy Kreme parking lot, we were both bleeding.
我跑向她，我很激动。我想我跑得非常快。她戴着耳塞，我碰了她。我抓住了她的肩膀。我是想碰她的肩膀，但我抓住了它。当我这样做时，她转过身打了过来。作为西田纳西人，我也打回去了。所以有几秒钟，她忘了我是她妈妈，我也忘了我是她妈妈。当我们打完在克里斯皮奶油甜甜圈停车场的架时，我们两个都在流血。
She threw her hands out to the side, and she said, Mama, what the fuck do you want from me? And I threw my hands out and screamed back, what I've said a thousand times to you today. If you could just not die, that would be great. And that's when it hit me. Just don't die. That was literally the moment, the moment my brain shifted. Because even standing there bleeding, I was looking at my baby, and she was OK. And in that moment, that was all that mattered.
她把双手向外一甩，说，妈，你到底想要我怎样？我把手向外一甩大喊回去，今天我已经对你说了几千遍了。如果你能不死，那就太好了。就在那时，我顿悟了。只要不死。那真的就是那个时刻，我大脑转换的时刻。因为即使站在那里流血，我看着我的宝贝，她还行。那一刻，只有这才是重要的。
Remember, Jessie was on her way to work when all this happened.
记住，杰西在发生这一切时正在去上班的路上。
I was in my nursing uniform going to teach-- I teach collegiately. I was going to lecture. I was going to stand at my podium, looking my very best, my very best professional nurse that I could possibly look, going to teach all these baby nurses.
我穿着护士服去教课——我在学院教学。我要去讲课。我要站在讲台上，展现我最好的一面，我能呈现出的最专业护士的样子，去教导所有这些年轻的护士。
Did you go to work?
你去上班了吗？
I did.
去了。
Wow.
哇。
I did.
我去了。
What did you say?
你说了什么？
The truth.
实话实说。
She told them exactly what had just happened. After that fight in the parking lot, Jessie started getting needles for Kaylen. Then she ordered Narcan. She got a big box to distribute around town. And inside was a Never Use Alone card. Jessie saw it and thought, huh, good idea.
她告诉他们刚才发生了什么。那场停车场打架后，杰西开始为凯伦准备针头。然后她订购了纳洛酮。她得到了一个大箱子在城里分发。里面就有一张“绝不独自使用”的卡片。杰西看到了想，哈，好主意。
I heard about Never Use Alone when I ordered my own Narcan from the New York City Department of Health. You have to go to a training before they'll send it to you. The training tells you how and when to reverse an overdose, and one of their PowerPoint slides mentioned the hotline. At the time, I imagined Never Use Alone was some official thing, like 911.
我从纽约市卫生局订购自己的纳洛酮时听说过“绝不独自使用”。在他们寄出之前你必须参加培训。培训会告诉你如何以及何时逆转过量用药，他们的一个PPT幻灯片提到了这条热线。那时，我以为“绝不独自使用”是个官方的东西，就像911一样。
But it's nothing like that. It was started, as Jessie puts it, by a bunch of drug users who were tired of watching their friends die. When she first volunteered to answer calls, the screening process to be an operator consisted of talking to one guy to see if you were a fit. The very same day, she picked up her cell and got connected to someone who was about to get high.
但它完全不是那样。正如杰西所说，它是由一群厌倦了看着朋友死去的吸毒者发起的。当她第一次志愿接听电话时，成为接线员的筛选过程就是和一个人交谈看你是否合适。同一天，她拿起手机，转接给了一个正准备吸毒的人。
I said, hello? And he said, I'm trying to reach Never Use Alone. And I'm like, oh, shit, I guess you did. [LAUGHS] Because I didn't know what to do. I mean, I knew I needed to get his address. I mean, that was kind of a no-brainer, right? But outside of that, I was like-- he was like, are you going to get my information? I'm like, what information do I need? He's like, oh, god. He said, you're going to let me die. And I'm like, well, I mean, it seems that way right now, so help me out.
我说，喂？他说，我想联系“绝不独自使用”。我说，哦，该死，我想你打对了。[笑] 因为我不知道该做什么。我的意思是，我知道我需要拿到他的地址。我的意思是，那是不言而喻的，对吧？但除此以外，我当时想——他说，你不需要我的信息吗？我说，我需要什么信息？他说，哦，天哪。他说，你这是要让我死啊。我说，嗯，看起来确实如此，所以帮帮我吧。
In the years since, Jessie's set up a whole system, a script that operators can use, a training regimen. But this organization is still basically run on a Google Doc and a prayer. I hung out while Jessie took one call after another over two days.
此后的几年里，杰西建立了一整套系统，一套接线员可以使用的脚本，一套培训方案。但这个组织基本上仍然靠一个谷歌文档和祈祷在运作。我待在那里观察杰西两天内接了一个又一个电话。
Never Use Alone. It's Jessie.
“绝不独自使用”，我是杰西。
The calls were intimate, sometimes joyful. One guy talked to Jessie for like half an hour about his life, where he was going over the weekend, his girlfriend, his health.
通话很亲密，有时很愉快。有个家伙和杰西聊了大约半小时他的生活，周末要去哪里，他的女朋友，他的健康。
You do good. You're drinking an ounce of water for every kilogram of body weight, aren't you? Didn't we figure that out the last time I talked to you?
你做得很好。你每公斤体重在喝一盎司水，对吧？上次我和你谈话时我们不是算出来了吗？
Another guy felt guilty for taking up Jessie's time. He tried to have everything ready to go when he called, and he apologized afterward.
另一个家伙因为占用杰西的时间感到内疚。他打电话时试图把一切准备好，事后还道歉。
Listen, if it wasn't for people like you calling, people like me wouldn't have nothing to do. I'd be bored as hell. I am so glad you called me.
听着，如果不是像你这样的人打电话，像我这样的人就会没事可做。我会无聊死的。我真高兴你给我打了电话。
He told her he tapes Narcan to his arm and sits on his porch after getting high in case he passes out. He hopes his neighbors will find him. There was no recovery talk. Sprinkled throughout these conversations were little reminders of how scary things are for the people who need this line. Jessie gently admonished one caller who told her he'd used on his own, a few hours before, without letting her know.
他告诉她，他吸毒后会在胳膊上贴上纳洛酮，然后坐在门廊上，以防晕倒。他希望邻居能发现他。没有任何关于“康复”的谈话。在这些对话中穿插着一些小提醒，提醒那些需要这条热线的人处境是多么可怕。杰西温和地训诫了一位来电者，他告诉她他在几小时前独自使用了药物，没告诉她。
You didn't call me. You know my heart would be broke if something happened to you.
你没给我打电话。你知道如果你出了什么事，我的心会碎的。
"I know that," he says. "I know."
“我知道，”他说。“我知道。”
OK. OK. Just call us. It's not a bother. Even if it's a tiny amount, OK, even if it's a tiny amount, it's OK. You're worth it. You're worth it every time, OK?
好的。好的。打给我们就行。一点也不麻烦。即使量很小，好吗，即使量很小，也可以。你是值得的。你每次都值得，好吗？
It's notable that everyone in this story has some kind of connection to addiction-- the people who started the hotline, Stephen, the paramedic, Jessie with her daughter, and actually, Jessie herself. 20 years ago, she had a real problem with opioids.
值得注意的是，这个故事里的每个人都与成瘾有某种联系——发起热线的人、医护人员斯蒂芬、女儿吸毒的杰西，以及杰西本人。20年前，她确实有阿片类药物的问题。
I did, back in 2002. I'd had a surgery. And my doctor put me on oxy 30's. I'm a nurse. Anytime I called for a refill, I got one.
我确实有过，那是2002年。我做了一次手术。医生给我开了羟考酮30毫克。我是名护士。每次我要求续开，我都能拿到。
For Jessie, there was no rock bottom moment. But after a couple of years, she started running out of pills. And she didn't want to risk her nursing license to get more. She quit cold turkey, spent three days sick on her bathroom floor. Then it was over. Jessie says her daughter Kaylen started using years later when a boyfriend introduced her to heroin.
对于杰西，没有所谓的“跌入谷底”的时刻。但几年后，她开始药不够用了。她不想冒着吊销护士执照的风险去获取更多。她立刻戒断了，在浴室地板上难受了三天。然后就结束了。杰西说她的女儿凯伦是几年后通过男朋友接触到海洛因的。
Jessie wonders about why a lot. Everyone has a why, Jessie says. Kaylen's why, she thinks, sort of has to do with her, their particular mother-daughter relationship. Jessie can be a hard ass. Kaylen, too. When Kaylen got pregnant at 15, Jessie thought Kaylen's boyfriend was bad news, so she blocked him and his family from calling Kaylen's cell. Kaylen was pissed. She threatened to move out. One morning, Jessie told her to go ahead and do it, so she did. They'd see each other every once in a while, but it wasn't the same.
杰西经常想为什么。每个人都有一个“为什么”，杰西说。她认为凯伦的“为什么”，某种程度上和她有关，她们特殊的母女关系。杰西可能很强硬。凯伦也是。当凯伦在15岁怀孕时，杰西认为凯伦的男朋友是个祸害，所以她封锁了他和他家人的电话，打不进凯伦的手机。凯伦气疯了。她威胁要搬出去住。一天早上，杰西叫她干脆搬走，所以她就搬了。她们偶尔会见到对方，但已经不一样了。
I found out I was a grandmother through a text message, when I had been at the hospital for two days with her while she was in labor. But she sent me home and said, I'll be fine. I'll let you know when something starts happening. And I found out the baby was here through a text message.
我是通过短信得知自己当了祖母的，那时我在医院陪她待了两天，她当时正在分娩。但她让我回家说，我会没事的。有情况我会通知你。我是通过短信得知宝宝出生了。
Oh, that's so hard. That's so hard because it's like, you go back, and you're like-- I don't know. Like, what should we have done?
哦，那太艰难了。那太艰难了，因为它就像，你回过头来，你就像——我不知道。就像，我们本该做什么？
I don't go back and have any regrets. I did the best I could with what I had at the time. That's all I got.
我回过头来没有任何遗憾。在当时的情况下，我尽了我最大的努力。我只能做到这些。
Yeah.
是的。
When it became overtly obvious that I was really not doing my best, that I was making things worse between me and her-- because we were always so incredibly close-- and when I realized, all right, you're fucking this up, you got to find a different way. You got to do something else because this right here is not working.
当明显看出我真的没有尽力，我让事情在我和她之间变得更糟时——因为我们曾经一直非常亲近——当我意识到，好的，你搞砸了，你得找个别的方法。你必须做点别的，因为现在这样是不行的。
Over the years, Jessie has watched Kaylen go back and forth. She'll have months of sobriety, then return to use. Kaylen's been picked up by the cops, had her photo posted on the local police department's Facebook page. While I was visiting, Jessie called Kaylen up. Kaylen said she'd come by to talk, but she never showed. I think Kaylen's part of why Jessie takes so many of these Never Use Alone calls. It's people like her daughter on the other end. She told me as much.
多年来，杰西一直看着凯伦反反复复。她会有几个月清醒，然后又开始使用。凯伦被警察抓过，照片贴在当地警察局的Facebook页面上。我拜访期间，杰西打给凯伦。凯伦说她会过来谈谈，但从来没出现。我认为凯伦是杰西接听那么多“绝不独自使用”电话的原因之一。电话那头就像她女儿一样的人。她也确实这样告诉过我。
I didn't want her to die. This whole thing is about-- every, every, every fucking thing I do is about her not dying. About her not dying, then about her and her homie not dying, and then about her and her homie and their homies dying. And now it's about the entire town not dying.
我不希望她死。这一切都是为了——我做的每一件、每一件、每一件该死的事情都是为了她不死。关于她不死，然后关于她和她的伙伴不死，然后关于她、她的伙伴以及他们伙伴的不死。现在，这关乎整个城镇的人不死。
When Jessie took that call from Kimber, listened to her OD on the line, she knew better than to expect that moment to change Kimber's life. And the next day, when Kimber thanked Jessie for saving her and then quickly followed that up with, "I want to use again," it didn't surprise Jessie. In fact, for Jessie, this was good news. It meant she could encourage Kimber to keep using the line, and it was an invitation to stay in touch.
当杰西接到金伯的电话，听到她在电话那头药物过量时，她知道不要指望那个时刻会改变金伯的一生。第二天，当金伯感谢杰西救了她，并迅速接着说“我想再用一次”时，杰西并不感到惊讶。事实上，对于杰西来说，这是好消息。这意味着她可以鼓励金伯继续使用这条热线，这也是保持联系的邀请。
So she did. She friended Kimber on Facebook, texted her for no reason. A few months after her OD, Kimber started calling Jessie "Mama." But Kimber would also drift away. When she did that, Stephen and Jessie would try to keep track of Kimber online, what she was liking and commenting on. "Messenger shows her active 6 minutes ago," Jessie texted Stephen at one point. "She hasn't even read my message. I text her phone-- nothing." "Yeah," he replied. "She's been leaving me on read," like she'd seen his message but hadn't replied.
所以她确实做了。她在Facebook上加了金伯好友，无缘无故地发短信。过量用药几个月后，金伯开始叫杰西“妈妈”。但金伯也会走远。当她那样做时，斯蒂芬和杰西会试图在网上追踪金伯，看她点赞和评论了什么。“Messenger显示她6分钟前活跃过，”杰西有次给斯蒂芬发短信。“她甚至没读我的消息。我给她手机发短信——没动静。”“是的，”他回道。“她没回我的消息，”就像她看过了消息但没回复。
A month later, Jessie tried Kimber again. "Hey, I haven't heard from you in a while. I hope that means you're good," she texted. Two days later, "hello? Are you good"? A day after that-- "hi, this is Jessie B., in case you lost my contact. It's not like you not to respond. I'm growing concerned." She added a heart emoji, pressed send, and hoped for the best.
一个月后，杰西再次尝试联系金伯。“嘿，很久没听到你的消息了。我希望那意味着你挺好的，”她发短信说。两天后，“喂？你还好吗？”再过了一天——“嗨，我是杰西B.，以防你丢了我的联系方式。这不像你，没回复。我开始担心了。”她加了一个心形表情符号，按下发送，祈祷一切安好。
Act 4, "Kimber." While Jessie was checking in with Kimber by text and Facebook, Stephen, the paramedic, he was trying to help out IRL. After all, he and Kimber lived in the same town. Stephen got Kimber back into rehab. Then he offered to get her into job training. A few weeks after her overdose, he posted a picture of the two of them on Twitter. Kimber had shown up at Stephen's July 4th barbecue.
第四幕，“金伯”。当杰西通过短信和Facebook联系金伯时，医护人员斯蒂芬正试图在现实生活中提供帮助。毕竟，他和金伯住在同一个镇上。斯蒂芬让金伯回到了戒毒所。然后他主动提出帮她进行职业培训。她药物过量几周后，他在Twitter上发布了一张他们俩的照片。金伯出现在斯蒂芬的7月4日烧烤聚会上。
A few months after that, though, is when Kimber went silent for Stephen and Jessie. Weeks went by, then months. And then Jessie got a text from a number she didn't recognize. It read, "hey, Jessie, it's Kimber. I just wanted to give you my new number." Jessie replies, "oh, hey, hi," four exclamation marks. Kimber was alive.
但几个月后，金伯对斯蒂芬和杰西保持沉默了。几周过去了，几个月过去了。然后杰西收到了一条她认不出号码的短信。上面写着，“嘿，杰西，我是金伯。我只是想给你我的新号码。”杰西回复，“哦，嘿，嗨，”加了四个感叹号。金伯还活着。
[KNOCKING]
[敲门声]
Is this going to bug you?
这会打扰你吗？
No, you're good. [LAUGHS]
不，没事。[笑]
This, of course, finally, is Kimber. Kimber lives in Vermont now. She's been sober for one year. The place she calls home is a tidy duplex where she lives with her little gray dog, Luna, and not a lot else. She didn't bring anything with her when she left Massachusetts, where she OD'd two years back. There aren't any family pictures on the wall, not many mementos. Kimber is growing plants, though. Nature has always been her thing. As a kid, she was the one who was always bringing creatures home.
这就是金伯，终于。金伯现在住在佛蒙特州。她已经清醒一年了。她称之为家的地方是一个整洁的复式公寓，她和她的小灰狗卢娜住在那儿，没有太多别的东西。她两年前在马萨诸塞州用药过量后离开时，什么都没带。墙上没有全家福，没有多少纪念品。不过，金伯在种植物。大自然一直是她的最爱。小时候，她总是带生物回家。
Do you remember Elmyra from Looney Tunes?
你还记得《乐一通》里的埃尔迈拉吗？
Yeah.
记得。
So my family called me Elmyra because her thing on the show was like, she would kiss and hug and squeeze animals until they died. And so that's what they called me because I always had some kind of critter or stuff like that.
所以我家里人叫我埃尔迈拉，因为她在节目里喜欢又亲又抱又挤小动物直到它们死掉。他们就叫我那个名字，因为我总是有某种小动物之类的东西。
In her new apartment, there's a little sunroom off the kitchen. Kimber wanted to make it into a greenhouse, but the radiator started leaking there, and the floor got soft. Still, this is a fresh start.
在她新公寓里，厨房外有一个小阳光房。金伯想把它改造成温室，但那里的暖气片开始漏水，地板变软了。尽管如此，这还是一个新的开始。
Do you keep Narcan around still?
你现在身边还带纳洛酮吗？
I do. I do. I carry it with me. You just never know when you're going to need Narcan.
带的。带的。我随身携带。你永远不知道什么时候会需要纳洛酮。
Yeah.
是的。
I just had to revive somebody the other day here at an AA meeting.
我前几天就在这儿的一个AA会议上抢救过一个人。
It was different, being on that side of things.
处于那个位置感觉不同。
You don't even think about the fact that you almost died. That's the crazy part. Like, I forgot about a couple of my overdoses because you kind of just fall asleep and don't even know that you fell asleep. I'd always get mad. You get mad at the person. You're like, what are you stressing out about? I'm here. I'm fine. What is the problem?
你甚至不会想到你差点死掉。那是疯狂的部分。就像，我忘了我的几次过量用药，因为你基本上只是睡着了，甚至不知道自己睡着了。我总是会生气。你会对那个人生气。你会像，你在紧张什么？我在这儿。我很好。什么问题？
And then I watched people overdose, and it's like three minutes between when you Narcan them, and they'll come back. It feels like an eternity, and all those things run through your head. This person's dead. I don't know if this person's coming back. And then you realize, oh. You're like, oh. OK, this was pretty scary.
然后我看着别人药物过量，就像给你注射纳洛酮和他们回来之间隔着三分钟。感觉像永恒，所有这些东西在你脑子里闪过。这个人死了。我不知道这个人会不会醒来。然后你意识到，哦。你就像，哦。好的，这真的太可怕了。
On that first day she called the line, the day Jessie answered and Stephen revived her, Kimber remembers waking up to a cold shiver rolling down her spine. She was looking down the hallway to the bathroom where she last remembered being, a bathroom now filled with cops. There was the suitcase she'd just lugged home from rehab. And then she got really, really sick.
在她拨打热线的第一天，杰西接听、斯蒂芬抢救她的那天，金伯记得醒来时感觉脊背阵阵发凉。她看向走廊通往浴室的方向，那是她最后记得待过的地方，浴室现在挤满了警察。那里有她刚从康复中心拖回来的手提箱。然后她开始剧烈呕吐。
After Stephen forced her to go to the hospital, she checked herself out within an hour and walked home, puking along the side of the road. She picked up more drugs pretty much right away. The whole idea of Never Use Alone's approach is that, as Jessie puts it, you give the callers time, one more day to fight their demons. And Kimber had a lot of demons. She says her parents both used drugs. When she was 17, her brother was killed by a drug dealer. The whole family kind of crumbled after that, Kimber included.
在斯蒂芬强迫她去医院后，她在一小时内办了出院，走回家，沿着路边呕吐。她几乎立刻就又买了药。“绝不独自使用”的理念是，正如杰西所言，你给来电者时间，多一天去对抗他们的恶魔。金伯有很多恶魔。她说她父母都吸毒。她17岁时，她兄弟被毒贩杀了。之后全家都崩溃了，包括金伯。
Kimber went to rehab on and off for years. She'd use a ton of drugs, realize things were getting a little out of control, and check in for a couple of weeks to "spin dry," as she put it. She'd get clean enough to go back to work and pay her rent, and then the cycle would start back up again. So the call with Jessie was not the moment things changed. That moment came over a year later. Things had gotten bad.
金伯断断续续去戒毒中心多年。她会用大量的毒品，意识到事情有点失控，就登记住进两周去“甩干”，正如她所说的。她会清醒到足以回去工作交房租，然后循环又会开始。所以和杰西的那个电话并不是事情改变的时刻。那一刻是一年多以后才来的。情况变糟了。
She says the sheriff had kicked her out of her apartment, the one where Stephen had revived her. Her car had been stolen and totaled. She was carrying around a backpack with her passport and birth certificate in it. But then it disappeared. Her cell phone was gone too. She had a friend who would let her crash, but the friend had a condition. Kimber had to call detox every day and try to get a bed, which eventually she did.
她说警长把她赶出了公寓，就是斯蒂芬抢救她的那间。她的车被偷了并撞报废了。她随身背着一个包，里面放着护照和出生证明。但后来它不见了。手机也没了。她有个朋友让她借住，但朋友有个条件。金伯必须每天给戒毒中心打电话试图弄到一个床位，最终她做到了。
The hotline is called Never Use Alone, but walking into rehab, Kimber was utterly and completely alone. And maybe for this part, you have to be. When she arrived, the nurse asked if she wanted medication. Methadone? To make getting straight a little easier? For the first time, she said no.
这条热线叫“绝不独自使用”，但走进戒毒中心时，金伯是彻彻底底孤身一人。也许这部分，你必须一个人面对。她到达时，护士问她是否需要药物。美沙酮？让戒毒容易点？这是她第一次说不。
So I went up to detox and detoxed with no medication.
所以我进了戒毒中心，没用药物就完成了戒断。
What did that feel like?
那感觉如何？
It was awful. I just remember going in, and I couldn't lay in the bed. It was so cold. They had the AC blasting. It was summertime. Of course, the AC is on. But you're going through withdrawal, so you're so cold. And I couldn't lay in the bed because they gave you like these thin blankets. So I went in the bathroom, where there's a heater thing in there, and laid on the floor. And they dragged me out. They wouldn't let me stay in the bathroom. They're like, you can't lay in here.
糟透了。我只记得走进去，我无法躺在床上。太冷了。他们把空调开得很大。那是夏天。当然，空调开着。但你正在经历戒断反应，所以你感觉非常冷。我无法躺在床上，因为他们只给你那种薄毯子。所以我走进有暖气设备的浴室，躺在地上。他们把我拖出来。他们不让我待在浴室里。他们说，你不能躺在这儿。
And so then I waited for them to leave, and I went into the bathroom. The only thing that felt good was I stripped down naked. It was a really small bathroom with like tile floors, so I had to throw my clothes out of the door back into my room and just lay on the tile. And I had the blanket over the heating vent, and I just like had the heat on there.
所以我就等他们走开，又进了浴室。唯一感觉舒服的是我脱得赤身裸体。那是个带瓷砖地板的很小的浴室，所以我不得不把衣服扔出门口回到房间，就躺在瓷砖上。我把毯子盖在暖气通风口上，暖气吹着。
But the coolness on my back and then the heat-- oh, my God. It was the only thing that kept me being able to sit through it. And I mean, I was throwing up the whole time. And I don't know how long I was there. It was a while. It just felt like days and days went on. And I didn't think it was ever going to stop. And I just kept telling myself that I could do it, that I really had the strength to do it.
但后背那种凉意，然后那种热气——天哪。那是唯一能让我坐下来坚持下去的事情。我的意思是，我一直在呕吐。我不知道我在那儿待了多久。待了一阵子。感觉就像过去了好几天好几天。我以为那永远不会停止。我就一直告诉自己我能做到，我有力量去做。
Kimber remembers all the details because she's really proud of what she did. Four days after she checked in, she sent Jessie that text from a new phone. "I feel like I'm in a stable enough place right now to reach out and let you know I'm back," Kimber wrote tentatively.
金伯记得所有细节，因为她真的很为自己所做的感到自豪。她登记四天后，用新手机给杰西发了那条短信。“我觉得自己现在处于一个稳定的地方，可以伸出援手告诉你我回来了，”金伯试探性地写道。
Jessie said, "everything that you've been through has prepared you for today. You haven't been wasting time. You've been getting ready. I'll support you however you need me to, every step of the way." For Kimber, it's been a year of big changes. She's in a new town, but she still doesn't really trust herself around her old crowd.
杰西说，“你经历的一切都为今天做了准备。你没在浪费时间。你一直在做准备。无论你需要我如何支持，我都会支持你，每一步都是。”对于金伯，这是发生巨变的一年。她在新的城镇，但她仍然不怎么信任自己在旧圈子里的样子。
It's interesting how this one call brought these three people together. Stephen told me when he first met Jessie, they didn't really like each other-- too similar maybe. But the call bonded them somehow. And Kimber, right after that call, she avoided Stephen, even though he kept reaching out. She was embarrassed. He lived in her town, knew all the police. She said she got to this point where she knew other people were sick of her bullshit because she was sick of her bullshit.
有趣的是这通电话把这三个人联系在了一起。斯蒂芬告诉我他刚见杰西时，他们并不怎么喜欢对方——可能太像了。但这通电话以某种方式联系了他们。金伯，在那通电话后，避开了斯蒂芬，尽管他一直在伸出援手。她很尴尬。他住在她的镇上，认识所有的警察。她说她到了一个点，她知道别人已经厌倦了她的胡言乱语，因为她自己也厌倦了自己的胡言乱语。
That passed eventually. Kimber took a trip with Stephen's family to the beach this summer. There are these photos of them, hanging out in the sand. Jessie, to this day, hasn't met Kimber in person, but they text all the time. On Mother's Day, Kimber sent Jessie a card. There was a picture inside of it, an ultrasound. Kimber is pregnant.
最终这过去了。今年夏天，金伯和斯蒂芬一家去海边旅行了。有一些他们的照片，在沙滩上聚在一起。杰西直到今天还没见过金伯本人，但她们经常发短信。母亲节那天，金伯寄给杰西一张卡片。里面有一张照片，一张超声波。金伯怀孕了。
I always said my body was too poisonous for anything to live inside. I had done so much to myself and just berated my body. And there was no way anything was going to be able to live in this toxic environment.
我一直说我的身体太毒了，不可能有任何生命在里面。我对自己做了太多事情，只是折磨我的身体。在这个有毒的环境里，不可能有任何生命活得下去。
Kimber's got a partner, Mikey. She met him in AA. They moved in together. This pregnancy was a surprise, but a happy one.
金伯有个伴侣，麦基。她在AA认识他的。他们搬到了一起。怀孕是个惊喜，但很开心。
And I think there was definitely a part of me that thought I didn't know how to be a mother. So when I found out I was pregnant, like even if I had to do it by myself, like I was going to do it. I'm 31 years old. I was sober. I moved to a brand new place, started with nothing. And I knew I could do this. If I could do everything I was doing, I could do this too. So I never for a second thought that I was going to not keep the baby.
我想肯定有一部分我，认为自己不知道如何成为一个母亲。所以当我发现自己怀孕时，哪怕不得不独自完成，我也要做。我31岁了。我清醒了。我搬到了一个全新的地方，从零开始。我知道我能做到。如果我能做我正在做的一切，我也能做这个。所以我从没想过不留住这个孩子。
Kimber still dreams about using drugs. These are absurd dreams, vivid dreams, dreams about smoking dope that turns into vanilla frosting. And most of the people she went to rehab with, they've gone back to using. These days, Jessie's still taking calls, sometimes 10 calls a day. She doesn't hear from her daughter Kaylen very much, but I did reach Kaylen. She told me she's trying to use less. Mostly, she said, she's sticking with weed.
金伯仍然会做使用毒品的梦。这些梦很荒谬，很生动，关于吸毒变成香草糖霜的梦。她一起去戒毒中心的大多数人，都已经回去用了。这些日子，杰西仍然在接电话，有时一天10个。她不怎么听到女儿凯伦的消息，但我确实联系到了凯伦。她告诉我她正在尝试少用。她说，大多数时候，她坚持用大麻。
As for Stephen, he says reviving Kimber changed his life. He'd been having nightmares about all the people he failed to save. After Kimber survived, he realized he didn't have to be the one pumping oxygen into someone's lungs to keep them alive. He could work more on the hotline instead. So he's doing that. He's even started taking calls.
至于斯蒂芬，他说抢救金伯改变了他的生命。他一直在做关于那些他未能挽救的人的噩梦。金伯幸存后，他意识到他不必非得是那个往别人肺里打氧气以维持生命的人。他可以更多地参与热线工作。所以他正在这样做。他甚至开始接电话了。
Stephen and Jessie wanted Kimber to come work on the hotline too. So she went through the training and just took her very first call. Now she's one of the voices on the other side of the phone, saying, put me on speakerphone, lay out your Narcan, unlock your door.
斯蒂芬和杰西想让金伯也来热线工作。所以她完成了培训，刚接了她的第一个电话。现在她是电话那一头的人声之一，说着，开启免提，拿出纳洛酮，解锁你的门。
Mary Harris, she's the host and managing editor of Slate's daily news podcast, What Next. They were our collaborators in making this story. If you liked what you just heard, Mary is such an amazing interviewer. And her daily show gets into the news in ways other people don't. You might check it out.
玛丽·哈里斯，她是Slate每日新闻播客《What Next》的主持人和执行制片人。她们是我们制作这个故事的合作伙伴。如果你喜欢刚才听到的，玛丽是个如此了不起的采访者。她的每日节目以别人没有的方式深入新闻。你可能想看看。
["TALK TO ME" BY CAVETOWN]
Mary Harris's story was produced and edited by David Kestenbaum. Our show was produced today by Alix Spiegel. The people who put together today's program include Bim Adewunmi, James Bennett II, Zoe Chase, Michael Comite, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Seth Lind, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu.
玛丽·哈里斯的故事由大卫·克滕鲍姆制作和编辑。我们的节目今天由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔制作。制作今天节目的人员包括比姆·阿德温米、詹姆斯·贝内特二世、佐伊·蔡斯、迈克尔·科米特、肖恩·科尔、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、卡西·豪利、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯、塞思·林德、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、纳迪亚·雷曼、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和戴安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Alicia Montgomery, Paige Osburn, Susan Matthews, Elena Schwartz, Aymann Ismail, Jeffrey Bloomer, Dan Kois, and the entire Slate and What Next team, whose work you can find at slate.com. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. Also, you'll find merch. We have the incredible Torey Mala-t-shirt. Check it out. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的执行制片人是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。今天特别感谢艾丽西亚·蒙哥马利、佩奇·奥斯本、苏珊·马修斯、埃琳娜·施瓦茨、艾曼·伊斯梅尔、杰弗里·布卢默、丹·科伊斯以及整个Slate和《What Next》团队，他们的工作可以在slate.com找到。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，你可以完全免费流媒体播放我们超过800集的存档。此外，你还会找到周边商品。我们有不可思议的Torey Mala T恤。去看看吧。再次重申，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He got fired from his job as an ambulance dispatcher because he was just way too chatty for the gig.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）传送至公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他被救护车调度员的工作解雇了，因为他为了那个岗位实在太健谈了。
If it wasn't for people like you calling, people like me wouldn't have nothing to do. I'd be bored as hell. I am so glad you called me.
如果不是像你这样的人打电话，像我这样的人就会没事可做。我会无聊死的。我真高兴你给我打了电话。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
["TALK TO ME" BY CAVETOWN]